yeah how many kids do you have we got
you over 40 down how many years you die
Oh probably over 20
don't tell me about your childhood you
grew up where and New Mexico little deal
right right about 40 miles south of
Durango Colorado no my mother had me so
she'd get a check my father was in the
service and she can eat it up and drink
it up and she tried to bait him so he
would take the bait and get killed and
he didn't take the bait he took off but
her second husband took the bait and she
got him killed and got some of the money
thought she'd gonna get the rest the day
she died God took her away for she sang
her song cuz she just kept up evil plot
she invited me to see her
I hardly I never stayed with her and she
nearly got my government in the prison
cuz my grandmother took us and run off
without her permission and she I'm gonna
get me on a Thorazine chip I was only 15
years old she bought thorns ane and
thought it was vitamins and she's gonna
click check on me the rest of my life
and so she got my grandmother in court
kidnapping charges and she saw the judge
at Aztec and the court reporter was the
wife of my grandma's husband's boss she
told the judge what happened and the
judge more my grandma's faith other
words why she'd been in prison the rest
of her life trying to save us oh it was
bad I'm telling you yeah I'm the mother
of six children each by a different man
that's how I know that this isn't as and
his Christian jazz does not get it and
[Music]
no I was consensual sex sorta when I got
pregnant each time one man I didn't say
to him and didn't want to hurt his
feelings no I kept Melissa here then we
thought psych drugs and like vitamins so
I swallowed the first ility and stopped
my pain and boy I was mine was cruising
good I call my grandma kid
get my chilled can figure out what what
to do and I become convinced that I
would get feeling good if I took some
side roads everybody was doing that and
thought they were like vitamins must
have and I ended up in hideous pain from
swollen Thorazine and took me three
months to walk it off I walked back for
the burning and hideous pain and by then
my brain was damaged so bad I could not
show the next time okay yeah I got to
get breakfast down and go ask somebody
feed the cats and try to get up enough
money to pay the extra storage we're
getting over here and I got Technic amp
and I ended up with BD and got treated
or I'm just gonna try to make it to oh
everyone get BD now I get real I get
real
week and I was sitting over from the
police station getting ready to try to
make it taller went to the hospital
emergency so when we gain BD somebody
raped me I don't know they they like to
rape me because I'm short they did both
mental [ __ ] anything like [ __ ] dog
especially if you're short and can they
figure that have a real night - aw man
they slam me against heavy objects now
they got me the other night my heart my
[ __ ] I tried to chain myself up in there
better